une du crack de plus qu'il ya quinze ans
déjà
une fois l'alcool du valium n'importe
quoi je vole et la manche je me
prostitue auront prendre leur vilain
tour soit cité du côté de leur vie
et si tu as 50 bas
là c'est tout il n'ya pas de l'histoire
du salut
vous avez été nombreux à réagir à notre
documentaire sur la colline du crack
ce lieu au nord de paris ou dealers et
consommateurs de crack se donnent
rendez-vous depuis une dizaine d'années
aujourd'hui la colline locaux ont été
complètement évacué pour brut
j'avais rencontré laurie cette jeune
belge de 19 ans enceinte qui a commencé
le crack très jeune vous avez été
beaucoup à être touché par son histoire
et si c'est trop dur de toxicomanes
j'ai 15 ans 18 rencontres
[Applaudissements]
je suis resté en contact avec lorie et
depuis ce tournage
beaucoup de choses ont changé dans sa
vie je suis en belgique chez home la
vidéo ça ça m'a permis de voir ta vu que
j'étais arrivé à un point où je pouvais
presque plus faire marche arrière
le riz est acceptée nous raconter la
suite de son histoire mais aussi son
passé très difficile
avec elle on va essayer de vous montrer
comment on peut partir de la colline du
crack se reconstruire même si évidemment
tout reste fragile
normand est de grande qualité aux
catalans je vais plus grandir moi je
suis enceinte
non marc ce jour bizarrement je suis en
belgique chez moi parce que j'attends un
bébé et je veux plus retourner à paris
on s'est finie je te jure si elle allait
finir comme les autres je voulais pas je
me suis vu comme ça comme une clocharde
et ça m'a fait bizarre j'ai vu tous les
commentaires des gens et tout ça ça m'a
fait bizarre
le reportage m'a vraiment ému fortement
je ne pensais pas en fait qu'elle
reviendrait à la maison et qu'elle
serait calme comme ça que je pourrais
avoir aller à log de femmes entre femmes
pensaient qu'elle serait en cours trop
dans ses désillusions et aidant je sais
pas il ya une atmosphère à paris qui
souffre qui se fait entre eux et c'est
vraiment un nom pareil
certaines autres ici pour une femme
enceinte de
c'est lors les mecs qui veulent te
plaisais mérite un bon je fais quand
même mes parents mes parents n'en
veulent pas ils voyais pas ce que
j'aurais dit j'avais arrêté de fumer
le crack c'est bon en première classe
est superbe on fait tout le bugue bon
dans ta vie et après ensuite un tu dis
mais [__] mais j'ai fait de la merde
quoi je fais ça mais c'est trop tard que
j'adore que ferait il faut quelques
années pour te remettre mentalement 5
j'ai vu offrir un jour du banco par
ailleurs c'est trop dur
quitter si c'est trop dur
bella ne manque
certes on a calé woerth
sachez dans le krach chaque fois ce jour
demain de communiquer et apitoyer les
jours jours à la con hier des années que
je suis sous sous somnifères pour dormir
parce que sinon je ne remets pas toute
la nuit je regardais mon plafond et je
me disais qu'est ce qu'elle fait où elle
est ils faits dégueulasses d'or
est-ce qu'elle n'a pas froid est-ce
qu'elle a un toit pour dormir
et quand j'ai pas de nouvelles pendant
je n'avais pas de nouvelles pendant deux
trois jours je me disais ça y est les
séquestrés quelque part je pensais à des
trucs horribles donc c'était vraiment
affreux
au niveau
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est pour les tissages on savait
déjà blessé léger
je cours je veux
c'est mon
comme ça pour moi
comme sur la chaussée
j pal avec elle sa mère
c'est sur elle
la mort
j'ai des grandes photos d'elle des
superbes photos d'elle c'est comme
beaucoup de souvenirs
on les met sur le côté puis la halle
était déguisé en claudette pour la fête
de l'école petit claudette mais c'est
quand les deux commencent à se
développer on monte sérieux à deux
mignonnes et a été comment laurie quand
elle était petite fille
bon c'était une chouette petite fille
j'ai très souvent anti j'étais grosse
main blanc tel aveu énormément
d'imagination c'est le regard apeuré à
la france fut mais avec un chrono à cela
oui ça c'est toi regarde ça c'est mon
père on le voit un petit peu juste
c'était moi tu as vu de l'âge déjà
j'étais dans une tente
[Musique]
alors ça c'est mes dessins
ça représente
ah le corps d'une femme
alors voilà mon histoire est assez
longue et riche et bon moment mon père
pendant un week-end sur deux me
tripotait de mes deux ans mais si nos
ennemis de mes 6 ans et demi avait sept
ans et demi c'était violent
au moins porter plainte avec moi classé
sans succès
classée sans suite j'étais perdu
ouvert trois ans et demi à l'aide le
mercredi après midi et avec elle sur
deux chez sont pas mal et quand elle est
rentrée elle s'est réfugiée sous la
table et elle voulait pas nous parler en
ayant trop d'aléas la douche parce que
son papa lui avait fait mal au sexe
c'est ce qu'elle m'a dit avec ses mots
d'enfant ça s'est reproduit donc j'ai
été déposé plainte et j'ai été à
l'hôpital au tivoli à la louvière et là
croyez pas trop comportement assez stud
du papa c'était là que toutes avaient
déjà commencé
sans le savoir ma vidéo de mes sept ans
vous n'avez jamais prendre comment
contourner
[Musique]
j'ai carrément fait descendre une
enquête un jeu ouvert une enquête mais
qui a été mal mal dirigé la clé et les
faits ont été classées sans suite donc
laurie a toujours eu cette cette
vengeance c'était pareil parce que voilà
on a cette impression qu elle avait
menti alors que ne montait pas assez un
enfant de trois ans et demi ne m'ont pas
pour des choses comme ça quand j'ai
rencontré le pape a dit monfils
on a pris un certain à certains espaces
avec le père de ma fille et à partir de
ce moment là avec le papa de mon fils on
a décidé de la mettre dans un internat
où elle serait vraiment hors contexte de
la maison et où elle serait loin de son
papa entre guillemets où il ne pourrait
pas entre guillemets la retrouver
[Musique]
pour moi ça a été la plus mauvaise idée
c'est de la m en interne parce que de
l'intérieur après sa chute et 20
décembre si kia trick
comme elle ne s'adaptaient pas avec les
autres enfants
un problème c'est quelle est donc la c6
dans un centre pédopsychiatrique car
j'avais du mal
maman avait un nouvel homme à nouveau
bébé
nouvelle maison à 12 ans je me suis
arrivée chaque jour je commence à fumer
des clopes seulement des paquets kamel
que je crabe vert moitié après à 13 ans
u traîner dormir dans des avec des punks
à chiens anarchie qui m'ont emmené en
fait qui m'ont emmené effet boutique le
fameux krach faire une force d'achat
belle moi quand je suis parfois je peux
voir ma grand mère elle ne suffit pas
aller vers la lumière d'où elle vient et
on nous répète sans cesse il est tous
assez variés comme la rave est ce
possible aux as le crack qui me met dans
ses illusions
la lentille
ici c'est un peu galère regarder ça en
fait
[Musique]
partie à l'heure
par exemple ça c'est mes dessins
ah non
tu vois bien
[Musique]
il n'y a pas que du salon des artistes
inconnus du parti je savais juste part
déjà j'espère et je crois
je sais être
lahlou
[Musique]
il ya des histoires il ya des poèmes il
ya des chansons finalement j'adore ben
oui c'est ça la maman aux riches s'est
déjà dit j'ai je verrai https a fait
j'ai eu quelquefois d'euros des dessins
assez goro c1
j'ai parfois il me faisait peur avec ses
dessins tout le temps d'écriture sa voix
qu'elle entend le vent souffle i fé noir
il plus j'ai froid je suis recherché
j'ai fait donc attention voitures qui
passent je suis rempli d'humour
différentes en passant par la peur la
poussée d'adrénaline le stress je
reprends donc une bouffée son nom deux
heures pipe à crack et tout redevient
comme avons complètement des français je
fais l'évident - littéralement ce soir
un client matin aux abords de la
chapelle sur le périphérique à la pompe
essence laurie elle a toujours tout
écrit de ce qui se passait dans sa vie
de ses jours et ses nuits de jeunes
toxicomanes et elle a aussi parfois
filmées
belga
oh why à des mondes est mort en
l'appelant je vois mon client il me
lance 10 euros une pipe ça marche non 20
euros tout compris ok ok je monte dans
sa poche
il veut la radio c'est un dodo avant à
peu près 30 35 ans cheveux grisonnants
balafré ce mec me fait peur c'est mon
client je le connais il est réglo ici
les meufs en manque de crack demande 5
euros/mois toujours minimum 20 aux
personnes en vie je me déshabille il met
sa capote elle tient coi niveau sexe
la question était gênante je vais
répondit vaguement prend un peu tout je
fais tout moi dès que la carotte et
place ça fait 20 ou profondeur craque
c'est chaud je n'avais pas que c'était
au temps c'est arte ce que j'écrivais
ans jamais je me suis jamais permis de
lire des trucs mais je vois quand je
voyais c'était l'écriture je mettais
dans une partie
au moins est à vue je suis réellement
quand j'écris j'écris tout ce que je
pense tout ce que je vois des contres
que vous avez su leur manière en bloc
les règles plus du crack nous dit quoi
et vous l'avez su comment j'ai pas du
prix du crâne j'étais pas au courant
mais après je vois que elle traînait
avec des gens qui ne faisait que ça donc
voilà et on se permettre ça maintenant
c'est trop tard c'est comme les fugues
on ne sait pas mettre sa main devant on
peut pas l'attacher au radiateur de la
maison et dire voilà maintenant tu vois
plus fugue et maintenant tu vois plus
prendre ça maintenant tu vas plus faire
ça parce qu'un enfant en plus on veut
lui interdire aux plus laurent vidal et
contre l'avis de ses parents parce que
c'est contradictoire à l'enfant et du
temps comme la gg
et pour la sauce de là
pas sûr
l'iowa est l'état
je sais
elle a fait sa propre expérience
et franchement on m'a même je n'aurais
pas été capable de faire tout ce qu'elle
a fait de traverser tout ce qu'elle a
traversé moi ce qui me faisait le plus
peur c'est quelques jours les pompiers
maple est qu'ils me disent qu'ils
avaient trouvé ma fille sans vie ça
c'est un truc ça me faisait peur peur je
vais pas mourir je vais à andré moi j'ai
un moura neto laurie qui font des
comptes non je vous rendez pas comment
mon frère je voulais a ordonné à faire
souffrir ce que j'avais vraiment mes
aïeux réveille-toi oreille et a lu
regardé des cadeaux h
les survivants de la ville basse de
dévorer ouest
tout un poème on dit merci un connard
je vois le dit
à lui me manque rien à faire j'étais lui
je ne vais pas ligue 1 ça me fait peur
parce que je sais qu'elle a encore en
contact avec des gens de paris et que
voilà elle est retournée plusieurs fois
à paris parce que justement elle n'avait
pas coupé les contacts avec avec des
gens tels que toi nous avons un toit
moi je leur parle tu vois pas ce que
c'est les seules personnes à qui j'ai
parlé pendant quatre ans donc du coup
c'est leur voile quoi tu vois moi
j'arrive pas à nancy dans la vie réelle
tu vois il faut enfin sage comme ça
enfin sa juste part avec eux on n'a pas
envie de faire les nouveaux locaux pour
nous montrer des jeunes qui fait en ce
moment depuis que tu es rentrée ouais
c'était des pharmas narration de mon
bébé cd baby et mini quêtes et sachez
qu'en même temps maintenant que tu fais
là ça fait un peu plus d'une semaine
mais ça va je verrai
franchement j'ai plus envie de fumer en
fait quand dans ta tête tu n'as plus
envie de fumer du crack bien le crack il
s'enlève tout seul de ta tête
si évidemment tu es tout le temps on
craquera crac crac crac dit je suis en
manque c'est ça c'est le truc qu'il faut
pas dire comment tu veux bien coiffé ou
en plastique sous les passages devant
il
loris tu étais c'était au fait est-ce
que tu refais réparer ou si jamais je
n'avais pas vécu ce que j'ai vécu je
crois que j'aurais pas pris conscience
que je suis bien la maison
tu vois rares fait le tour du monde sait
ce qu'on veut c'est être à la maison tu
vois sa maman ouais je ne fais pas la
veille